when Luke Skywalker became one of the
force at the end of Star Wars the last
Jedi fans were left sobbing sniffling
weeping and wondering whether they'd
ever see the legendary Jedi on the
silver screen again sadly we now know
that Luke truly has passed and the
thanks to actor Mark Hamill we know what
really killed him taking to Twitter on
Monday October 22nd Hamill shared two
images from the comic-book adaptation of
the last Jedi specifically the panels
that Illustrated Luke's death on the
planet octo both the film and the comic
adaptation depicted Luke's passing as
somewhat tranquil but Hamill has a
completely different idea of what went
down the actor revealed that the force
actually killed Luke likening him to a
drug addicted relapsed after years of
sobriety and ultimately overdosed the
force killed Luke you have to
acknowledge the irony in his fate almost
like an addict that kicked his habit
cold turkey remains clean for decades
only to reuse just once and then
tragically
overdoses as those who have seen the
last Jedi will remember Luke vanishes
into thin air
leaving nothing but his cloak behind
after he reconnects with the force and
creates a projection of himself in an
effort to protect his twin sister Leia
and saves a few surviving members of the
resistance from kylo Ren in the first
order
Luke's active bravery was successful as
he engages in an intense duel with kylo
infront of the abandoned rebel alliance
based on the small remote mineral
planets of crates when kylo swings his
cross guard lightsaber at Luke he
realizes that he isn't battling a
physical Jedi but rather he's fighting
against a force projection the camera
then shifts to show Luke dying on acto
staring into the Setting Sun that's
quite a stark contrast compared to how
Moss report of the circumstances
surrounding Luke's death on the surface
Luke's passing wasn't all sunshine and
old Iranian flame lilies and goblets of
blue alien milk of course but it did
feel markedly serene as if the scene was
implying that Luke was passing from one
realm to another
moving from completely a physical
journey to embarking on a spiritual one
according to Hamill however there was
turmoil and pain bubbling underneath as
Luke was unable to shield himself from
the corruptive side of the force
Hamill's take on Luke's death is
interesting for sure as it suggests that
the force has something addictive and
lethal to even the strongest of my
though he's gone from the land of the
living Hummels Luke isn't entirely
missing from the galaxy far far away the
actor previously confirmed that Luke
will appear in director JJ Abrams
episode 9 due out on December 21st 2019
fans have theorized I'll circle back
either in flashback sequences or as a
force ghost like Anakin Skywalker Yoda
and obi-wan Kenobi have all done in the
past to continue training ray in the
ways of the force and perhaps teacher
one final infinitely valuable lesson
some have even speculated that Luke will
return to haunt kylo Ren which would
admittedly be pretty hilarious to see
but while Hamill clearly isn't shy about
talking all things Star Wars after films
have been in theaters for a while he's
not in the business of addressing
theories ahead of a movie's release so
fans shouldn't hold their breath for him
to confirm or deny any rumors in
mid-october 2018 Hamill tweeted I
mentioned keeping my hashtag Star Wars
opinions to myself and what happens it
triggers an avalanche of questions about
the next one yes I'm in it other than
that just consider a Episode nine
comments so the matter in which Luke
will return for episode nine remains a
total mystery but there are two things
of which were absolutely certain there
in asking Mark Hamill about anything
related to the upcoming Skywalker saga
installments and don't even think about
doubling and using the Force
it's too dangerous kids you don't want
to end up like Luke do you didn't think
so
[Music]